yah always poppin as your man Dean
Edwards welcome to the other another
episode of the [ __ ] protocol man
I'm laughing because sometimes the real
world kicks in and the phone rings are
we gonna bring the music in wants to get
right about now son yo we're back in uh
in the all things comedy studio man out
here on the west coast the West Coast as
they say let's go sit the best hosts but
I'm from the East where's the Beast so
it's all good it's all gravy baby yo and
um yeah I know as always make sure you
subscribe to the podcast on all things
comedy follow like comments the [ __ ]
multi-protocol big up all things comedy
the network big up all these shows on
all things comedy check out some of the
fabulous ones like gene tail raise uh
let there be talk man and also you got a
gut in edwards sucker comic rant but
bigger than all that side got a big up
this this this podcast which you gonna
catch pretty much part to this this
conversation hosted by none of my man
sitting to the right the man with the
plan
my man Philippe Philippe and spiders
host the the brilliant what's up fool is
it what's or what what's up it's what's
up what's up fool and I got my man
Philippe right here my brother from
another mother
Philippe was poppin man how you doing
what's up fool chillin chillin man Chile
we were trying to make this happen it's
been like a year because cuz cuz I
remember when you had John Salley yes up
on your joint and we saw each other cuz
Felipe obviously like I said he records
on for all things comedy as well and he
usually record on Wednesdays at noon
yeah Wednesdays at noon and anytime I'm
in LA I usually you know it's funny I
always I always ask do you guys have
available ahead Aaron's like we have 10
o'clock no nobody else was to come in at
this hour deed but I'm a morning person
and so when when I found out I was gonna
be here it just so happened you happen
to reach out at the same
in time I was like oh that's perfect I
can you can do mine and then I can do
yours and tell the people that are
listening all the fan we have like
family out here so all the fam tell them
what they can expect when they listen to
- what's up fool
what's up fool is my podcast it's raw
it's real it's about recovery we tell
them we talk about um recovery okay
now using in recovery but somehow is
leading on to recovery
okay and a lot of drug addicts listen to
our show non drug addicts people are
trying to stop do these doing drugs
people are trying to find a way to UM
just get away from doing drugs and right
you know trying to find a hobby okay
well we get a lot of people who just
finish doing just barely stop doing
drugs right and then listen to our
podcast listen to my stories and they
click on it in a matter it don't matter
the white black Asian we got people in
Ireland right and now we just got a
letter from our that letter from a guy
in do talk Mormon
and it's funny story letter I'm first of
all man he goes um I'm one of the white
guys talk about the privileged German
French you know I'm white right you know
he's wired at Sporto well now you say
Utah I was like I automatically decided
even if he wasn't white house like he's
white boy could be some more noticeable
of Fiji right and you're a long letter
how he's gay and um his struggles being
gay for all his life and till out drugs
you know trying to hide the feeling okay
a lot of [ __ ] a lot of drugs in and one
day he was like feeling like doing drugs
again please gay and I guess I just for
some reason I just open your podcast and
I started listening and I binge all of
them mmm Wow any wonder he wanted to
take me for hours things over and I'll
do be nice he said my stories help them
because I and then he was telling me
that I'm somebody in his family died and
then he felt like going doing drugs
again and he said that I'm a bug why
don't one of your guests on your show
embodied home cuz I'm a crackhead right
just do a lot crack em hmm and every
time I tried I tried like stopping I
always found a way to find an excuse to
just right justify walk well that was
discount good you say I think of one of
his parents with best friend died and um
he freed why that's a good excuse to go
buddy huh
right right I need this to comfort
myself in this time of morning yes so I
always found like an excuse to get high
like all the Dodgers want no bump right
but isn't that how isn't that how you
know addiction sort of wins and why
addiction is so hard because it's so
easy to to find an excuse to make an
excuse and and lapse back or slip back
into that dark dark hole yeah and I'm
also like like if you never saw your
parents make up mm-hmm
you know your parents always broke there
were five but you never saw makeup you
know I never showed of making up you
only sort of- versus the past yeah right
and well and they never said I'm sorry
in front of us you know they never got
it all together and saying it's a man me
and your mom were fighting you know even
if you were to say watch these actions
true that gonna poo I was acting a fool
but no one has ever brought like a lot
of people fight and they don't bring
their kids in a meeting let them know
what happens so their kids go on
thinking that okay you just fight and
then somehow it gets better some way
right but we don't know that they made
up so that was might think I will fight
with somebody with a girl or somebody
and then just stop being their friend
right forever
Wow Wow because now is is this in the
midst of of your addiction this is right
like smack data in the midst of your
addiction so at what point did you
realize because as I think that's that's
very important that especially being a
parent
once you become a parent you you sort of
think of all the things that you did
that weren't done in front of you like
say for instance if you were if you were
young and you didn't see you saw your
parents argue and they still wear them
together so there was
a makeup but you didn't see them here in
your mind automatically you planted like
I well maybe maybe they're just together
cuz we're here cuz we the kids are here
but if we weren't here because then your
mind is allowed to wander yeah you never
have closure there's no closure and so
when in your life did you realize oh you
know what I'm going about this the wrong
way instead of me cutting people off let
let's have a conversation and maybe find
resolution I didn't know idea really
really it did it just happen on the
southern the other southern near my
head's away away away I can let this
person walk away okay my fault okay okay
well then I just called a benefit man I
know my father I'm sorry right
don't go was it whether it was it in the
midst of were you still in in addiction
or were you in so Brown sobriety
okay so sobriety helped help yeah all
for clarity you know which is beautiful
and what's that person someone that's
you like because I'm imagining that it's
someone you you had to care about them
yes to say you know what I'm sure yeah
there's something in me that's telling
me I got I can't let this person walk
out of my life yeah
what what did it was it was it your wife
that it's not my wife and other people
cuz I'm I'll be with my wife 10 years
okay okay lovely late yeah we're married
now we're together I think eight okay
and I do a bit about it now you know I
know they're like I thought I know you
don't know this there was somebody that
long that you're not married to them
just in your head you're married today
right right you star said it's my wife
like we were we were together so long
that that uh yeah that's wife right
that's how that's how dudes get over now
guys if you watch the rest are so white
dog that's wifey right there and and
women like okay and yeah but but a
married do like yourself by so we like
nicer that's the slickest angle out he
was like oh he called the wife is you
like all your baby I'm like yeah ain't
no ring look
no commitment just took your bow now
anyone do you got like seven other wifey
she got a you got a hair room full of
white ice everywhere so she's been at
your corner for a long time yeah man
you start getting pressure from the
family yeah you're gonna marry mama
would when your kids are like come on
soon you're kissing Riley
yo pops you know I mean I know you
called the waiver could you you know I
got a different last name from a mouse
it makes a confusion at the PTA means so
can you uh make something happen that's
funny that's funny side oh you know so I
like I like to get people's uh people's
story you and and dozier I don't know
Felipe I think the first time we work
together was was economics only that
makes me bored hummons with our board
members Russell Russell Russell Peters
and the funny guy funny guy um yeah I
remember we met that was uh we shoot
that at the elbow Aldo ray LDL Del Ray
it with me you as a bunch of comedians
yeah Eric Andre within the Eric Andre
Mike Mike Mike
big smile big smile yeah you know I'm
talking about right there Mike II
Winfield Mike you were infield yes you
win Phil I think Achmed med I made it
any man oh yeah those are come with our
borders right coming yeah yeah I made a
man some tripoli tripoli yeah um lot of
people think yeah mostly barely knew he
was right right right right though who's
this young kid well you know it was
funny about about that taping I always
likened it pretty much like like most
sort of all-star showcases and what was
different about this for those that
don't know comics without borders uh it
aired on Showtime networks here in uh in
the US and it says I think it's
available on Netflix and whatnot but
what was dope was they set it up where
they put a headliner and a feature so
the feature would do I think like 10
minutes and the headliner would do like
20 minutes yeah and
and and then they also did like a little
interview segment that they would they
would bump into prior to your set so so
what I enjoyed about that was your your
it reminded me of um Enter the Dragon
with Bruce Lee where like had the best
of the best you know like like kung fu
movies where you had this one cat in his
style might be praying mantis another
dudes like tire crane style you know and
everybody came together and was like
Iowa you're gonna rock out I'm a rock
out of let's see let's see who who comes
with it you know and it was it was a
dope experience and uh and reconnected
connected cats like myself and yourself
but also I I had known Russell Russell
and I knew knew each other from like the
early 90s when we were both starting out
really yeah yeah man up and uh Russell
was from Toronto and I started out in
Rochester his listeners are saying no
he's from Brantford right and so we used
to do uh we would do shows together up
there that's it and so it's always
always dope when you are it's nice just
when you see people like you just
mentioned a budget cast it's nice that
we're all still out here yeah I've also
uh I met Eric Conger and that's that I'm
a manometer the Russell the author
mother sure I think I did ok ok and um
he remembered me he goes Filipa you like
my dress you know that my drug dealer
back in New York
that's it cool so uh he ended up being
on the Eric Andre show yes yes but in
the show like four times or does dope as
um um episode that we're now Hannibal
Buress said well I have a I have a
co-host too now but he is a host right
right can have a co-host get have a
co-host co-host yeah so here's my host
and then Philippe sparse and I come out
with no t-shirt that's funny
oh you want Tracy Morgan style no no
Sartre is not a party to you come in
without a shirt I went without Tracy
Morgan finally oh did you win like stage
showing in Manhattan with Toyota Comedy
Festival no I don't know
what it was oh no you did uh you did hot
97 yes
April Fool's Comedy Jam yes which is
perfect cuz your pockets what up fools
so so eight year date before Scott I
remember when you with a big show man
and we'll the guy smiley yeah Tracy
Morgan DeRay Davis was it the way Tony
woods woods he shot and some other chick
name wrong
Roxanne or Roxette share the podcast
she's a black woman
I wasn't Marazzi not marina no no I
don't know that it and then Tracy Morgan
like I told her my name or a bunch of
time what's your name
Felipe Esparza I'm knowing I just wanna
make sure I pronounce it correctly
that's what he said then it went it went
when he was Bremer birthdays he didn't
uh he said my name with no consonants
Halle Berry's I hope you like that and
then you didn't have the crowd like who
the [ __ ] then I said I'll give it up for
Kevin Hartless doing windmills backstage
she seemed bad he did stay gonna make
you mad yeah you got you got a spark in
his eyes that's what he said you got he
got tools
you got tools he knows how to know his
name I tried were hosted in a couple
times you know I was gonna mess it up I
didn't mean it one personal I love you I
love you Philippe I know how to say I
know how to say it now cuz you earned my
respect
yeah what he said yeah it's rated number
yeah that's how you knew a party was a
party was when uh Tracy so I now I gotta
go find those episodes of Eric Andre
show bag cuz I bet that show was weird I
remember watching I was like this is
this is whele book you know what what I
also dug about that show was Hannibal
and because I remember Hannibal and
Andre and Eric went mate when they both
was you know still sort of like just
like newer cats in New York and I love I
love
that like when one is on the other pulls
the other and that's how it should be
yeah reciprocity when I get on I'm gonna
put my man's on advice or which I which
I know you do with your peoples you know
which which is uh which is cool I wanna
I wanna I want to take it back to the to
the beginning some way from cool you oh
la la okay alright okay okay the capital
of East Los Angeles he sees East LA LA
yeah man but I was born in Mexico
oh yes snuck in fair and square okay
okay so so so Trump if he wins he's
coming for you Lane that coming from me
ma'am legal yeah i bunk it's coming with
people who are not legal okay now he's
coming for I don't understand how like
somebody could be living this long 15
years 20 years I never got your [ __ ]
together right there's a point where you
supposed to say so what on the way man
you kids can be like hey get married
sooner or later you know I mean you
gotta get married to this country soon
or later can be America's side shake
whatever hiding in corners and return to
the Americas main man shows that we
gotta go hide so right right right I'm a
good like I don't know member my parent
we came here and like in this late 1770s
okay and every that our our green cars
in 84 okay so then eighty too long to
start working towards yeah but we had a
plaque my dad are we have family here
already set up gotcha
man if you it's hard when you come to a
new country you don't know no bro I
don't know buddy your refugee yes you
are you're a Syrian refugee right did
did uh did your parents speak English
hell no they still don't speak English
the data speak English but they wanted
you you to learn it so you were their
translator yeah dig it that's my I'm a
new specially gonna be caught Felipe
translate this haha for real oh that's
hilarious this forty as I'm a dumb
psychic to come up Arizona my it's funny
my my dad um he's been in another
America long enough where he could just
take his you're citizen test in Spanish
oh wow I didn't know you could do that I
see my dad found a loophole yeah yeah
you could take your the US Senate the US
Senate the US
citizen test in any language you have
you want I didn't know that if you're
Chinese you've been here 30 years and
you were thinking in Chinese yeah Wow
cuz we welcome everyone yes so my dad
was like reading a studying his tests
all in Spanish what colours is a flag
iseul Blanc ie
Roja nice who the first president was
jorge washington--
yeah man he took it in Spanish and I'm
citizen you I gotta keep my rights yeah
yeah he votes my mom boats or math
American citizen I'm not yet I got
married I thought Hernandez would be a
shoo-in was he married a white woman
automatically but now he's do not take a
test yeah yeah they think they want you
to commit you got to commit they're
gonna check her background yeah
make your legit yeah yeah you have arm
what hey that's funny but let me I'll
come back to that so you you grew up
he's East LA was was it a challenge
being you know the parents or the child
of a immigrants that didn't didn't speak
the language or where all of your
neighbors speaking speaking of Spaniel
as well and therefore it wasn't really a
challenge until you went out into the
the American like the school system I
got here when I was like five or six
okay so um I picked up English right
away okay I guess what I was young and
there was no one all my classes were in
English there was no English in the
second language so everything I was
taught with an English gotcha I never
like pulled to the side and somebody
translate it for me that's good we all
learn the same ABCs right so we're all
learning at the same level but now it's
different because that now they have our
English as a Second Language classes so
they have a special class for special
needs people who don't speak English I
think that slows things down I was gonna
say do you agree with that or you know
yeah cuz especially cuz you came up in
an era where you they were just like you
you're thrown into them yeah because
you're in a class where everybody speaks
English sooner or later one of the
students gonna help you right it always
happens like another kid or take you on
his wing listen listen Paco this is
where you say this okay it's lagging not
be lying right right no that that's uh
that's interesting that you say cuz i I
I feel the same way I'm like instead of
I don't use it that's not necessarily
dumbing down but right raise up like
because you'reyou're gonna be forced to
to step your game up you were forced to
step your game up also based on not just
the situation at hand but also I'm sure
there was being being a child you're
like I don't want to be in back you have
the pressure of you don't want to be the
one that sticks out as not being able to
communicate in English like everybody
else so that that that made you work
harder you know yeah versus saying oh
hello everybody else is speaking English
as a Second Language so I'm not really
pressed to have to you know so whenever
my mind a woman I talk now I'm speaking
English and she's answering in Spanish
and I hope your questions in Spanish
okay and I'm mastering English that's
interesting she don't speak English to
me she's in all in Spanish but I speak
any label mom how was your day or me DF
where we end well at the end of it but I
yeah Mira esto min soo who was there
with you
Oh estaba Rossa Lupe mm-hmm did you have
a good time CCC mm-hmm never never have
an accommodation at that but she
understand she understands everything
I'm saying okay but I can't find what
the right words in Spanish to say I can
speak in English but I can't speak in
Spanish but I don't know that means I
don't know the big Spanish words you
know like a poor like upper hand is easy
comprende but there's all the words I
don't know like crowd I knew that one
summer I don't know man I'll just go to
service you know so so you're growing up
in the in in what well East LA it was
like a notorious neighbor cuz in New
York we knew about easy to East alone he
said like same way wu-tang clan was not
not to be f-word like East LA you didn't
go
a mess around so it was a rough
neighborhood yours rough man or I grew
up in Boyle Heights
just like the suburb with the inner city
before you get to East LA like wants to
leave downtown LA going east Boyle
Heights is the first neighborhood and
then when you get to it Indiana which is
about four miles away and that's east of
the Angeles okay okay
he's Los Angeles has more more houses hi
we're in the flats
okay so we're mainly but like um it
would be considered like from New York
and the the shittiest neighborhood next
to the battery when the battery was in
[ __ ] okay okay in the industrial areas
in the area right here that's where I
grew up well all industrial factories
people going in and out of work all the
time so it was good growing up where I
live because it was a lot of factories
outside out of our neighborhood we could
go break into okay that really is worth
a kid not really work because um are the
last generation before us [ __ ] that up
for us alright more way because they
used to get worked there and then it'll
[ __ ] up and then come back and Rob so
then all these warehouses they knew our
zip code they knew our addresses so once
they they knew our street numbers so
once somebody from they say um this guy
wants to live here wants to work here
but he lives on 16:34 East Fifth Street
he lives in the number 616 34 to 33,000
oversaw the housing projects so there's
two application away Wow Wow so it bit
them in there yeah so we couldn't get no
jobs there ever day so a lot of the a
lot of the older homies that there were
already there almost 12 14 December 1925
they would hang out like at this truck
stop like day laborers and they'll just
hang there all night all morning and
then like a truck or pulley and go yeah
mmmm only four guys to unload this truck
and then of my friends will go in there
unload it saran wrap it put it on
pallets and a gal getting some money
right and he's gotta go back to the
neighborhood and spin it on drugs the
circle of life it was like the loser job
like oh man [ __ ] them I don't want to go
work in the trucks right right because
we still I still see day laborers in
Brooklyn like like it's funny because
you see a lot a lot more armed
immigrants now like if if you go back
even just a decade you didn't you didn't
see it as as uh as prevalent as you do
now which which always amazes me when I
hear people complain about you know go
back to my yelling working those jobs
like you know I mean like I because I'm
as especially as a veteran that like I
understand fighting and defending the
the country and and the rights of the
American citizens but I'm like you know
the promise I also know that the system
is set up to not let certain people get
in it's harder for certain immigrants to
come to the States legally so I that's
not I'm how many I want letters I want
anybody listening sending me a message
oh so you're saying people should just
come in and leave I'm not saying that
but the people that are here illegally
it's not like they're just they're like
I'm in America now I made it and just
laying around actually working like
trying to work or working you know to
make make life better and become
citizens you know at least at least uh
from from afar looking in from outside
looking in from our perspective that's
how it looks do you get do you get do
people right right
based on your podcast and hit you with
like a man I don't like what you said no
we don't okay that's good that's good
i I've had comments I'm really had any
negative comments I've had like like
they're a couple of cats that listen
that will uh like catch if I say if I
caught something or a fact that was like
off or even like some some reference and
they're they're good about that but
fortunately the fam that listens they
they don't they don't get too harsh I
wish they would than that way I know
they subscribed
that's true they pay attention right we
get a couple of people there's a guy
that
his name is Jose Rivas at the method
name he lives in Japan and he's from the
LA from East LA okay
he's our military no he's a translator
oh wow so he translates our podcast in
Japanese to his students so the student
get a little bit of a history of Ali so
dude that's high so they're over there
right
there's a cut uh we said a merge he buy
his merge and this is Japanese girl who
wears or what so fool has shown no idea
who we are what she wears
I like that though Japanese Japanese man
I mean they love American culture it's
all good but you know what they love
more
they love the Latino culture they love
it they love the hip-hop culture and
they love the whole whole low rider
scene yeah like something like you were
like you were like go on YouTube or
wherever you're on someone's page and
you see somebody didn't you see that
[ __ ] again another photo yeah
then you see this word but you don't
know him right but you wonder why all
these fools know him but you don't know
yeah right start digging around research
into the research and you're there out
to our looking for the fool we didn't
even never met up yeah you're on an
Internet journey so I followed this guy
who I will see an icon in photos right
and I fell Shimon in old school photos
like rapping then I saw him with
nowadays wisdom sons of anarchy
but I went through the whole list of
watching this dude who was a [ __ ] is
this guy he watched his transition
yes his growth and I went for all the
way back to the late 90s some guy and
here a tattooed face he's a Raider fan
he's at the two phase he's a big old
harbor area tattoo in his stomach and
I'm thinking like I'm already this guy's
a crazy-ass dog right from somewhere and
he's been on some movies but he's like
he worst old-school gangster like with
the zoo soon right and then he has a
Japanese lady oh wow and I wonder how
the [ __ ] the Japanese lady beat this
gangster from Harbor City woman 10 his
name was Emma so I follow his name was
MC Pancho MC Pancho would
MC poster I went to another interview
and I went and I saw a whole interview
about him
I'm invite him to our podcast and even
never met him digging but I learned
everything about him you know and I'm
glad that I used to be quick to judge
people you know cuz I'm from the hood
right and I know when somebody the loser
but I I saw him as an old man this guy's
like he said something about him or else
he wouldn't be here and he hosted the
the tattoo convention in um in Denver
with some hot chick with a lot of
tattoos you know the beautiful girls
that she has 700,000 followers this guy
only has two thousand followers on
Instagram but he gets too cold yeah I
mean he has street cred somewhere yes
somebody was like we gotta get a poncho
MC poncho so I thought this attack II
think I have to make all my money
selling drugs you know I'm already still
type of this guy right right and I
looked him up no this guy is the most
humblest realest nicest person you'll
ever meet and he's telling me the story
he goes he's telling I feel like telling
me this story but he's not telling me
stir in the whole world he said that he
started making cassettes in the 90s and
we've given him out
I couldn't start a mixtape okay like it
like like MC Hammer selling out of his
car and you're selling him selling them
didn't really make that much money
selling them but you always had a job he
said that his album and made it to Japan
they were selling his cassettes for
$5,000 no he saw 5,000 copies at $50
each do never get a money from it
these Japanese got bootlegged it and
they sold 5,000 copies for 50 bucks each
but so now they're like they're
searching for him like searching for
sugar my man
I'm tired of this scene that guy so they
searched every gays yeah Rodriguez and
then they flew him out too he don't he
was a big star in a little ass ton of
Japan little town and he's taking photos
everybody
he's like Danny Trejo over there but
that's crazy and I found this out in two
hours searching them and this all
happened just because you kept noticing
in his face yes on different different
posts and so you like who's this guy
and long story short he's just a
longshoreman from the harbor area San
Pedro working there 26 years
he goes man he was he was a hit up hit a
rough past when he was under 20 when 21
got a job in longshoremen Union man
everything he's had he bought from his
job he knew nothing he didn't get enough
no money from movies no money from those
albums self-made guy okay give me the
chills man like yeah man it's like a
cool guy they say he sounds like a cool
cat I love the fact that you just used
stumbled upon him you know it wasn't you
didn't you it wasn't like you were
saying that you know who who can we who
can we interview on my show you were
just curiosity you know and and I think
that's the power of the internet that
people don't what people do utilize it
but you know cuz the Internet is useful
for evil or just used for bad purposes
so often I mean even something as simple
as just like internet porn like think
about how many times you going to
internet pointing like yeah you're like
man I should be doing something more
productive but you're like ah but but
interracial uh well just go to daytime
no you have all day to kill yours buddy
by doing errands that just did just go
he actually Lots himself a time of the
day there been times where I'll call he
has he doesn't mind me saying this which
is why I can say I'll call him he's like
a man you interrupted my session you
know it's my moment I'm like oh my bad
you know hit me back you know in an hour
after you find just the right scene or
what have you but it's nice that you
used it for something good something
positive to find out something positive
that that might have not only inspired
you but and gay
you chills but also your your listeners
and people that support you your podcast
it's crazy because then the juror that
the girl he's dating a TV made in Japan
oh when you said that I was like oh okay
well it made sense and she dresses like
there's photos of him with a bunch of
Japanese and those Japanese look like
they were raised here in Pico Union the
valley they look straight dug because
they love they love the lights loading
blood out man right Wow Wow that's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah we had on our show we had
meat glow did you really from let him
found that [ __ ] somewhere is he
still actually still acting okay
he's big little like some actors are big
and other country he's big in Germany
okay some eight well it was amazing
about entertainment man is you never
know especially now with the Internet
you never know who's peeping who's
checking you was checking you oh no you
know I I'm always amazed when I have you
know people you know hit me up you know
from where from safe safe from HK from
Hong Kong you know we have a listen
supporter ELISA and she she checks out
I'm like really yeah but I love it I
appreciate when people people reach out
cuz you don't know people like you said
people will stumble upon you that's
that's the one thing I miss about having
my afro is I know with my when my hair
was big it stood out you know it was
because like you said it was a when
someone the same with your look you know
you have a lot of hair you have it you
have an interesting style you know and
and coming up the way I came up you you
had the more the more your swag was
based on your originality you know
that's that's what's missing I think in
in entertainment specifically hip hop
and pop music today is everyone's sort
of his cookie cutter even even like a
lot of say the rappers a lot of rappers
all look exactly the same on this
understand it sounded a lot of enemies
we get it but you know you got it people
don't like you we get it alright moving
but is Hayden right right you know and
uh and so Jack and chimp is stacking
cheddar stacking chips and I hate them I
trip on the rappers likes just hanging
out of their house and saw a lot of the
guys are unknown those are the guys I
followed - yeah I find a rapper like I
don't know who he is but I follow him
and then there's this other car with
stacked up running right and I'm like
I'm watching this like this 2016 bro
I'm thinking it's a bank giving off that
much cash nowadays cuz you walk into a
bag you should have closed your account
then they're gonna give you no cash
right gonna give you a check yeah walk
out of this you go to the check cashing
place it who's cashing these chairs
Casas who's paying these rappers in cash
that's 40 promoters that better try to
clean them on a man clean this guy that
I saw a movie once was Little Richard
and he was one cat that used to get paid
in cash back there I never remember it
and the movie I was told I could just
picture that movie right away man
because I wanted to be there I'm Little
Richard I just got paid and he's paying
everybody off and he opens up his
briefcase
and he's getting [ __ ] up and he's
taking money out of the briefcase and
paying everybody off then he sees a
young white couple and then he started
up make out with her so then you start
making out making out man is [ __ ]
orgy stars right after I mean the whole
time he had the money right there I'm
thinking how easy is to rob these people
yeah yeah yeah that's I I remember I
think Chuck Chuck Chuck Berry also like
a lot of those cats back in the days man
because which I guess makes sense
because a lot of them probably didn't
have bank accounts you know especially
if they work they were black of color
they didn't have the access to the band
like hey I'm taking that money which is
now like a wives tale where they uh they
get the money and put it under the
mattress I I ain't gonna front
I got some times like when I said this
is my merch when I sell my t-shirts I if
whatever I sell cash I you know I I put
look I'm look the the the
the the the guard in my head is like now
you can't tell people exactly where
where you put but well if I if I make a
couple hundred dollars selling t-shirts
I don't always deposit that money that's
that's fun money you know that's that's
the money or I'll go read up and get
some more shirts and then take what you
know some addition and stash it like in
a sock sure you know just - money and
your house even though you're living
alone I love like like especially in the
winter especially in New York because
you you're running through a couple of
different winter winter coats and so I
love to just like sometimes like if I go
if I like it if I go to grab like say
just food at a restaurant and I paid
cash say say the bill is you know say
$60 and and they know the bill is like
45 but I want to leave leave something
give like 60 take take a tip I'll take
that five or $10 and just dump it in my
pocket but I do that and it accumulates
so then by the following year if I'm
just like walking around I reach in and
have like $40 in my pile you know every
so often I'll just say here you know
what here just stashed like twenty
thirty dollars here's - oh yeah I'm
still that's old-school I guess that's
real old-school I want watching that
Snoop Dogg when he had a loop done had
his family show and his arm his son was
playing in the closet and he grabbed one
of his coats and you trying to be snoop
outside of the house and it took out he
put in his pocket there was $10,000
stacked up Wow and you get in trouble of
course I was gonna say yes oh no you
can't do that little homie you got to
you got to stay out of Daddy's pockets
oh I like to reach that level man when I
forget ten thousand dollars in my pocket
I'll do you better I remember I think
was DeRay somebody was saying uh they
were hanging out at Eddie Murphy's crib
and I get this right we're at Eddie's
crib and and it was like envelope
Dreamworks envelope
DeRay or whomever was like it was that
it was like well it's just man it's uh
it's just a residual it was like that
you know I have a couple hundred
thousand or millions just a six-figure
check just sitting and it was nothing he
was like oh yeah that's you know that's
chick I'm uh I got a I'll get that
deposit if if you are I get a check for
$1,000 you're immediately I'm like ah
here let me make sure I go to the bank
and put cuz I always the fit my fear is
always that's the day that there's gonna
be a fire in the house and the check
he's gonna get burned out and I'm never
gonna be able to retrieve that check cuz
sags it'll be like oh no we have to go
through a procedure you have to saw I'm
real paranoid and that's that's that's
coming from being broke man I remember
before Jamie Masada used to give me
Friday and Saturday shows at the Laugh
Factory
hey buddy I'll be there on Saturday
could I had a show down the street I'll
be there on Saturday while the big
karmakar coming in and say it was all
Philippe you're in the show now I'm in a
[ __ ] show man here okay my $60 from
the from the box office
yeah I did that last night as a matter
of fact but I both Ian Edwards and I we
were uh we were doing he was he had a
spot at the Soho House Sarah mellow
shout out to mellow she's doing a show
at the solar house every Tuesday and we
went our way from the Soho House and
there was some agent was having a party
in scat and E was having a party CAA a
cat at the den I think then the dental
in Sunset so on our way I said do you
know say yo you know what swing by swing
by the factory cuz I have probably like
six seven checks there from last time I
was out here but I think that they
expired oh man they expire that's arias
that always bugs my month later yeah
yeah like you gotyou got pick up your
checks quickly and it's been I haven't
been out here since what are we in
October I was out here I think in March
April and so I was so I kind of knew
that the checks weren't going to be
there but I said maybe I tried maybe I
catch that because I think they expire
after like there's a hundred
eighty-eight one at 180 days yeah six
six-month doing
so I just missed it oh well here we go
through the Laugh Factory checks when I
hear the little box you start looking at
all those celebrities right right
[ __ ] gonna pick up these tricks
I'll take it yeah yeah just a couple
like John like that dude on me what's in
there mama thievery love it
no not John love is in the other guy the
one he goes down you can do it oh you
can do all John Schneider yes right yeah
chicks in there and I'm like man these
guys don't give a [ __ ] you're right
I'm waiting forget to check with another
comedian right here yeah yeah in line in
line wait for your check sir
so so that's actually that's that's
perfect transition so when did you you
know I'd do my research and I know they
were like five things you want to do
before you you died yeah be happy and be
a be a stand-up comic when did you
decide when when did you have that
conversation with yourself that made you
decide you wanted to become a stand-up
uh I was like 22 okay and it was like I
was in a rehab okay and our rehab was
nondenomination so you could be Muslim
or Jewish or non non-religious to be a
nurse so all right we have but just to
attend the meetings though so hold up so
real quick this is this is new news to
me I didn't realize that certain rehab
facilities are based on whatever your
denomination is yeah most of them are
Christian O'Connor our place was called
live again recovery home in Saugus okay
pastor hewan okay now that guy has a
story man because like everybody will
come in here for being drug dealers or
being a drug addict heroin addicts meth
addicts and the pastor was a bank robber
oh wow Jane passed Juan was getting it
in yeah man he was a heroin addict he
robbed every bank in Fresno Madera
County - Wow and like in the 70s bro he
robbed all of them and he was being
chased by the FBI he did time in
Leavenworth Kansas and he escaped
he escaped why he got released on a
computer error like the a-team turn turn
turn that ain't gonna play it Hannibal
no he's saying that he got our released
from County Jail on a computer error and
as soon as they said you're out he took
off he ran from the law for 10 years he
said he got stopped by Border Patrol and
left that food naked in the desert took
off his car and drove it to Mexico Wow
and then he 10 years afterwards he was
helping you know he stole burned up in
Mexico open up a rehab in Mexico and
help addicts then he went back to LA he
was still living under another name and
then he just said [ __ ] this I can't live
like a lie right I'm gonna turn myself
in he turns himself in and the judge
asked him what the hell you've been
doing for the last 17 10 years and he
gave him the whole story I'm telling you
and she came time served Wow Wow
so good for him because he is
interesting how the the the the burden
of the lie the burden of the guilt made
him say man this is you know I'm telling
I'm helping people get their life right
right I'm not right so let me just go
and it's and it was a blessing in
disguise because it actually it it
worked his benefit that he cleared you
know the judge cleared his uh clear
display wow that's that's quite okay so
you're in you're in rehab is this your
first time in reading yeah I've only
been to rehab once okay I was um I was
there from I don't know when I came into
July and I was there for a whole year
and I got out the next year a year and a
half later on December huh now you know
this I only wanted to you know part
pardon my ignorance because I you know I
fortunately I've never had an addiction
that had me have to experience or
understand what rehab was and for also
the listeners out there that might not
know so I always wondered when you're in
rehab you do you also are you
functioning in society with a normal
9:00 to 5:00 job or is or is life really
just about you them helping you read
rehabilitate yourself out of your
addiction and therefore you don't have
any other you know type of vocation that
you're focusing on no rehab that I was
in it was in house so I have to sleep
there and I can't leave or I could leave
I walk away anytime I want
right right but I didn't want to leave
okay I was just I had this fear if I
leave imma die okay and if I don't know
they put their fear on us but most of
the people that would leave they don't
gonna be using drugs immediately I
remember talking to this guy and I
didn't talk him out of staying but I'm
talking about about leaving he said man
Philippe I gotta go I'm leaving right
now
and that's the wall go pack up your bags
and look you know talk me out of it no
man you want to leave it's up to your
problem man right now you're it was your
decision and I'm gonna force you to stay
here right but you know what's out there
I'm gonna tell you what's out there yeah
and um they would leave but I never left
because I was afraid I'm gonna get my
ass I was gonna die out there because I
already had beat someone up so I'm I
just needed to get away from violence
right so when I was in there I was like
a crackhead but most of the people that
was there I guess crack was new at the
time people I was going in for a crack
now it's math but most of the people
they were heroin addicts and then like
you know it's funny when I want my drug
was stronger than yours as like black
people in Jews trying to prove who who
suffered more so same with with with
drugs which I didn't realize that heroin
addicts her legnani from that cracking
nothing you got this hair on your mayor
and they'll be like you just a
pincushion man Wow
but it was funny one too white to watch
cause crack is when they come into
recovery it's just depressing man
because you've been I'm doing drugs and
hiding your problems for what a year two
years so you never had a chance to see
work see the world as it is you know
without running from it so crackheads
they cry a lot they get depressed they
want to kill each other it's just a
constant battle in your head like it's
just living with total regret every
single day
so you so crack was your choice we have
poison well-armed had you tried other
drugs like I'm always because you and I
are pretty much off age and did you
start crack when crack first hit in the
80s or were you a late were you late to
a crack party and if so what made you
say I I'm not gonna get addicted like
every other crackhead that I've ever
seen you know I mean I cuz that's less
smoke most people I don't don't smoke
like the the thought in our heads is
like how are there new crack heads when
you know crack is that in a thousand you
know I mean nobody nobody smokes crack
and went you know I mean so what made
you say you know what I got I got this
nothing man I really I didn't tell
myself nothing like that like I didn't
say we're gonna quit or I'm gonna get
addicted like how did you start yeah I
was sad I was sad
we had just dropped acid tabs like three
nights ago
mm-hm and we were all wired up we're
walking around the housing projects you
know man like it's the project's who
could be dangerous if you're not from
the price rise but if you're in it
you're in it to win it
right everybody knows you right knows
everybody knows everybody watching your
back even as the gang they're even if
you're not part of the gang you're part
of the gang right because everybody in
that neighborhood is part of the
neighborhood even if you're not in the
gang just as we're from I'm from my
little village all my you one of those
cribs no are you one of those other
Mexican guys didn't know you're one of
them so and I got hooked right away
because my brother was already hooked he
was doing crack but then my brother got
shot by the police and I were all
depressed it was like the mood in my
neighborhood when my brother got shot
and my other two friend were killed by
the police it was like the mood New York
felon 911 okay where you lost somebody
big and you and we're all we're all cool
with each other we were hugging each
other I was like I hate writing our IP
on the walls
poor friend never
friends and even the Korean guy from the
liquor store who's been given it was
selling those 40 ounces our whole lives
he felt bad that my brother got shot oh
wow we were over there buying beer to
get [ __ ] up and um he gave me a big
hug
and he walked with to the back of the
store and he gave me two cases of beer
hahaha he said so worried about it kill
yourself helping enable how many really
card you like I never do that was his
version of a hallmark moment oh they're
not as funny man my goals as the when I
was sports 15 is to be like this I say
his name man he's still alive man but
I'm pretty sure you want to hear this
podcast seems to be this book this guy
named Bungie this brother man and now he
was cool bro he was cool
I don't know if he was a blood or he was
a New Mexican gang you know this guy was
crazy claimed both ha for Street he got
range
yes man he was a kind of man he was a
kind of dad you want you know and the
kind of gangster you want but if you've
not your friend you don't want him well
what mate what would you say cuz it's
got he liked what you like I would watch
him work man and I say mime do it I'm
gonna do everything he did you man I
will there was a liquor store the same
liquor store he that guy gave me my my
free beer well people all member to use
a lot of warehouses they get paid on
Friday ok
they will get paid it will cash their
checks at all i financed a our liquor
store right right Lali Christo
Charlie's and then on first and boil and
he'll go first and glass street he were
waiter I'd imagine you're cashing your
check and then this big low dog is
watching you cash your check right there
who's standing there right here buying
nothing he's just standing on the other
side everybody but he's standing by the
candy and you're catching your check and
he's standing right there with a tank
top big he's wearing one of the OH
school old school gangster hat I know
you remember like that Fedora type
generic man with a corduroy had with the
two golf clubs it was a corduroy
gangster hat uh-huh and it had and it
had these two golf clubs on it the logos
yeah oh yeah Pauline neiman-marcus
I don't know what it was okay and he's
standing there just to his dismay Lok's
on he got yes you know --xx and then his
coat has cornrows are in rollers mmm so
he was three rollers yeah yeah and he's
standing right there and just some
regular Joe's castings check $270 that
fools asking for $30 yeah yeah and they
gave it I don't know how they gave it
but some of them gave it of course
his big to sit niches watching them in
like do I give him 30 or does he take
the full 217 around the corner and in a
ichigo's they get him an or Bob Joe you
don't have to say Bunji Bunji Bunji no
banjo clock tower fool yeah he knocked
our fool out dog then the cops show up
and I'm there like picking up the little
change their father put it in my pocket
yeah when I'm putting my change in the
stupid ass dumb Housing Authority police
because we have the projects back then
had to hurry yeah I'm legal in New York
and it's funny like we knew those fool
got off work at 4:00 and then the real
criminals will come out right so man up
those four guys came in there didn't
even give a [ __ ] who did it
Bunji was gone his homies were gone it
was only the little kids the next
generation right right we were like two
runs like City over City of God
yeah little kid here and the cop just he
went out damn and you pointed a shotgun
inside the store and even he just
pointed both of them pointing into the
store
damn I don't know who called and said
those are all robbery there was no armed
robbery right strong-armed right right
right and I was like I was watching that
and then every time a truck you see a
truck like a coca-cola truck or a board
Weiser truck already gonna board
Budweiser truck will come in and then
alcohol to the liquor store they will
get robbed like someone to open up the
cases and run off with a beer and that
happened all the time man yeah like our
neighborhood was in a the type of
neighborhood to start a business
mm-hmm right no cuz you weren't gonna
get the local love in the way you wanted
it so those were my heroes mm-hmm
then there was another guy named wolf
and this guy man was one of those
Mexican gangsters man that was crazy
like you know some people have a silver
tooth mmm I don't know how this guy did
it but he got a hit of a red ruby and
one of his tooth but I always wondered
having it embedded into the tooth like
that this guy will with was name was
wolf
I think it's pleased long gone but you
were one of the it was barf man and just
like bunchy boss and I'm this guy man I
saw him fight one of those police
Authority cops
I just stopped them and they said wolf
goes how the [ __ ] you know me by wolf
mmm like right away like who told you my
name is right and I got to stop him and
then I just saw him I grabbed the police
officer by the for the chest
I started pounding his face and then
those other his homies came in he
started bashing up the car and then see
when you live in the housing projects a
lot of people were not that violent they
were not involved in that situation but
they were affected by it like the LAPD
all the congos show up and it will put
our neighborhood on lockdown right okay
and then like nobody can go outside
their homes while the police gather the
whole neighborhood that there was that
they were like the cops the LAPD was
line up 11 deep and start from the back
of the projects 6th Street and walk all
the way to first just walk the entire
ProCare the whole world yeah and
everybody go in their house
but well that time they made it to the
other side everybody was gone already
everybody cleared out right right Popo
yes so so Wow
there's uh you know cuz I we I want to
break this into two UH two episodes
instead of doing just one long
one and we stopped it so when did you
start smoking uh when did you when would
you say cuz obviously you were doing
other drugs but they sort of acted as a
gateway but butt crack became the one
that really affected you heavily yeah
and around what age were you I was like
nineteen nineteen okay put it man i was
a kind of guy man you can't tell [ __ ]
off and percy don't knock your ass out
Wow and in this ass and you're such a
sweet guy [ __ ] from the from the
alley podcast festival children [ __ ] off
an Instagram uh-huh just cuz I told him
that his partner was all white and it
was all white it was a [ __ ] white
uh-huh each other [ __ ] off we're all
gonna [ __ ] him up Rome you see when I
found out how small and weak he is [ __ ]
this [ __ ] tell me to [ __ ] off
because I know that [ __ ] from the Lala
dollar whatever Park is he is he would
never tell me that [ __ ] in person I
don't think he'll tell anyone or [ __ ]
off in person if you're listening right
now [ __ ] I hope I never see your
ass right right that's [ __ ] your apology
apology be a person man grow some
[ __ ] if you tommy was [ __ ] deleted
oh really when I told him a white tie
[ __ ] it was deleted and his
[ __ ] arm
[ __ ] off stood there for a bottom two of
whole week [ __ ] that [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah people people to be liked
by black stuff man on the internet like
I would never tell someone to [ __ ]
alright even if they're smaller oh you
have bad Joe I really know you got a
respect people I'll call you out but
don't tell me to [ __ ] off and they said
there's also there's a difference
between cuz you you called them out on
something that was your podcast Ally
podcast you [ __ ] was all white right and
then another southern like latino guy go
see what it is man is that like when a
bunch of white people are hanging out
together they're used to that they're
used to seeing all white that's why
white comics don't step into a black
night or a Latino night because that's
not their vibe right they don't know
that but that's a Latino comic we go
everywhere or black or black or coming
any comic color everywhere well in there
and the
reason in this distant you know to
inform and not not necessarily to offend
people have to understand that the
majority of our someone said to me
recently they said you know you have to
understand like we everybody want you I
just want to be American but you all
created the term african-american when
when people think American they just
think automatically well that's a white
American and if if you're other type of
American there's a - you're - it's oh
you're african-american you're a Latino
American you're you're Asian American
you know we didn't we didn't create that
y'all created that so the same thing
with would say the comedy club scene or
any scene if if I the the majority of my
life any space I go into I know how to
find comfort in that comfort in my own
skin being myself in whatever space I'm
in because the majority of places you go
to the majority place I go to our
majority white our majority Caucasian
versus refried Friday's at the improv or
wherever where they have the Latin night
and now you you might have like that's I
always respected Billy Byrd
bill burr to look this weird saying it
in the studio right but bill but what
what I always talk about Billy was and
the reason Billy is so successful and he
could now be bill and not Billy is
because he always would go into any
space in New York City and do him he
didn't change his set he didn't change
his style he didn't pander - uh - here
I'm the I'm the white guy in a black
club so I'm gonna go on and I'm gonna
dance and get people like oh go white
boy because he's knows about student
loans right he just did his act you know
I mean it's just like when I would go
into a black room or mainstream room I
would just do my act you know I'm so
that sort of cat I have no idea who
you're talking about but I'm offended at
somebody that's coming at you for just
saying a man hey what's up with
sometimes on white dogs and you're an
hour late homey right there's a
say no late a lot of other people I know
me [ __ ] nothing from our lake a girl
from Australia right what the [ __ ] right
yeah yes so um we just got heated my
city dog just pay respect a respect he
respects if I will go to Boston I would
look for a Boston Common right David um
I forgot his name
bring your whatever name right which but
you show you show you shall respect not
only for the city but also for everybody
that's been there
excuse me prior to you being there by
saying you know let's let's get some
cats that are that are from out here so
that uh so that we can uh you know
expand expect diversity in my opinion
diversity is wonderful because it opens
it opens up your palette as well as the
people that are around you to Palace so
like you being on my podcast doesn't
hurt me it only opens opens up my ax
listeners and supporters and fam to what
you do in your story and vice versa
me being on your podcast is just gonna
make people say yo that dude do that was
I check this dude out you know I mean
and that's that's called reciprocity
that's how the world supposed to yes you
know versus being in this vacuum like
what I did I did I'm Jay Larson yeah a
lot a bunch of people off Felipe a bunch
of people from their their listeners
listening to me now yeah when I did the
Bert Kreischer right they followed me
all this got an OG yeah damn yeah man
everybody saying well he's the most real
this guy ever hello dude and I did I'm
Jay more stories the the champs I did
that [ __ ] twice right I could do it
twice I thought I lost all my energy on
the first one yeah but you gotta you
gotta like man you you you you are you
actually reminiscent of it's funny we
were talking about Tracy cuz you and
Tracy you're both y'all both got stories
for days you know that's what's
entertaining people like that's that's
my man 50 queer we go back like spider
poison 8tracks
go back like spinal cords and eight
tracks we talkin egg hey listen man look
I um like I said we gonna do do
two episodes and then I'm uh i'ma do
Felipe's out podcast so you know what
we're we're gonna wrap up the part one
of this uh this episode man we're gonna
wrap a part one Philippe where can
people find you on the Internet's on
Filippis world.com
ok Felipe's world.com they can get your
or your specialty hell IP es wor LD calm
ok and as always y'all know me bad shoot
I am Dean Edwards on all things social
media just follow at IMD Nevers cuz
that's that's who the [ __ ] I am
you know y'all stay tuned for next week
we're gonna have part two because I
didn't I meant to mention at the
beginning of the episode man this is the
first time we've had a winner of Last
Comic Standing rocking out with us in a
little room on the [ __ ] mark protocol
so y'all make sure y'all keep listening
keep supporting keeps commenting and and
we'll keep bringing that flavor Felipe
Esparza thanks for hanging out on this
episode homie we got you on next week
yeah what's up fool and y'all make sure
y'all check out me on what's a fool I
don't know lady this Friday see ya
that's come on I'm out you know what I
guess this this little bit it's up
already cuz I'm dropping this on Monday
I dropped my choice of Monday so yeah
yeah I'll check me out on what's a fool
immediately all love is your man Dean
that was 2 fingers busy